music man lead us off
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello and welcome to this MIT virtual
town hall and thank you marty marks of
mi t--'s music and theater arts section
for that wonderful opening music from
Jerome Kern I'm Alfred Ironside vice
president for communications welcoming
you to the second in a series of
gatherings across our community in a
moment I'll hand off to Raphael rife
president of MIT and our outstanding
panel of faculty and staff but first a
few reminders on accessibility
we are live captioning this event and
also have simultaneous sign language
translation notices for both were sent
out in advance we also have an
audio-only call-in line for those
without a strong internet connection and
this event is being recorded and will be
available at this URL for viewing any
time now to our format as with our first
town hall we have gathered some of your
questions in advance but this time we
will also be responding to your
questions live as many as we can get to
you can submit questions through the Q&A
feature at the bottom of your screen our
purpose today is to offer an update to
share what we know about the complex
factors shaping the decisions ahead of
MIT and there are a lot of factors to
talk about so let's begin with pleasure
I passed the floor to mit president
Rafael Reif Thank You Alfred in to
students parents and staff faculty and
alumni warm greetings for from Cambridge
I try to be more precise on greeting
from gray house we are all members of
the MIT community and that means we
a lot of things in common among those we
care for one another and we care for MIP
Kohli 19 has affected and is affecting
all of us but it's affecting some much
harder than others so as we work on
solutions to the challenge of Kobe 19
large campus let's recognize this be
sensitive that each of us is
experiencing confident in differently
and each of us have different points of
view
so let's respect those differences and
let's show empathy for those who are
going through a very difficult time and
it find solutions that work for our
whole community
we had closed the campus about eight
weeks ago so four weeks ago we had our
first Town Hall since that Town Hall we
updated a community on a financial
situation
we also share some decisions on the
summer today's Town Hall is not to share
additional positions actually today's
Town Hall is mostly to share our
thinking about decisions we have yet to
make end of that list is when and how we
will reopen a campus we have not made
that decision yet
we have many people from all parts of
campus working together to come up with
scenarios on how we can reopen the
campus and win these all these
individuals are organized working groups
and the leaders of all those working
groups are with us today to share their
thinking and to answer your questions in
addition to them we also have members of
a central ministration that would be
available to ask your questions as well
one of the most important issues that we
have to consider before deciding how and
when to open the campus is the state of
the public health situation and the
state of medical science and for that we
have a terrific guest today a person
that I deeply admire an MIT professor of
the practice was also the director of
the Reagan Institute of MTH MIT and
Harvard and this is dr. Bruce Walker he
is on the frontlines of much of the
research going on these days to overcome
commit 19 and he is a terrific adviser
to all of us Bruce thank you so much for
joining us here Bruce the picture is so
complex I would like if you tend to just
clarify it for us so before we open the
campus we have to pay attention to
social distancing and testing tracing
and medical treatments
perhaps your vaccines what can you tell
us about the landscape how
because you got vice us to consider the
landscape in terms of reopening the
campus you know it's it's it's really
there's an experiment going on right now
that I think is giving us knowledge that
helps direct those sorts of decisions
and that experiment is happening in
hospitals across the country Mass
General is one example that's where I
work as a clinician and the the reality
is that using personal protective
equipment and monitoring for symptoms
has resulted in the in health care
workers actually being able to be safe
the problems for healthcare workers have
come when they haven't had masks to use
and they haven't had the additional
personal protective equipment when
they're right interfacing directly with
patients I I think the the emerging data
suggests that if you if you wear a mask
and everybody else wears a mask the
chances of transmission drop
dramatically I think if you add to that
frequent temperature monitoring the
chances of transmission drop even more
because you can identify people with a
fever right away and remove them then
from the from the community and so what
what we need to think about is what what
resources do we have right now what
knowledge do we have right now that
might guide us and I think the knowledge
we have is this suggestion that a pretty
firm suggestion that that judicious use
of masks and and social distancing or
physical distancing and and symptom and
temperature monitoring will have a
dramatic impact on on transmissibility
can you I mean I see you all as you
probably are missing or knowing there is
tremendous anxiety on the campus and for
that we need to use the information you
told us at the same time we also have to
try to
have a crystal ball on what will we know
that is different from today perhaps
four week from now perhaps eight weeks
from now if we will know nothing
different then new mothers will make a
decision right now but if things are
changing what can you tell us about that
and I know I'm not suggesting you can
tell us exactly what's going to happen
nobody has a crystal ball or perhaps you
do but my main point is what do you
think might change why is that which
brownie should wait us one last week and
I suppose deciding today I think there
are couple things that will become
apparent one of them is surveys to
understand just how many people have
been infected and just how close to herd
immunity
we may be herd immunity is when enough
people have been exposed that the
likelihood of one person encountering an
uninfected person it diminishes to the
point where ongoing transmissions become
less we don't yet know if antibodies are
protective but there's reason to assume
that those are and we'll we'll know more
about that from animal experiments that
are ongoing right now I think that will
help to guide that but I think we'll
we'll begin to get a sense of just how
widespread the the infection has been
and I think that that'll be important
information for us to understand I think
that's also as tests become more
available we'll be better able to
monitor for example the whole population
at MIT - when students come back to
follow them I think the other really
important thing that's a little bit
further on the horizon is the
development of high-throughput
inexpensive saliva based testing for
virus itself and we we sponsored a
webinar on on Friday that I'd love to
send out make available to the people in
this town hall to watch there are some
extraordinary advances being made by
professors at MIT and their graduate
students and postdocs that give me
reason to think that we may not be that
it's within the foreseeable future that
you can get up in the morning and brush
your teeth and at the same time take a
q-tip and and swirl it around your Nerys
and and stick it in a tube and have it
churn color if you're infected and not
turn color if you're not we will get out
of this predicament that we're in
because of Science and Engineering and
Technology and MIT is the is the focal
point of that in the world in my view
and when you watch what is happening on
this on this webinar from people like
Feng Shang and and others you'll you'll
have reason to be hopeful first thank
you so very much for joining us I really
appreciate and you have always been
available to us to advise us and we'll
keep abusing of your time for as long as
you let us really so much you're welcome
I think we're going to move now to what
I mention at the beginning we have
different working groups working
together to try to come up with
scenarios for us for the Fall
we have working groups on residential
life or on academic research on the use
of physical space and staff and
community they are appeared to be
different but the two-phase that all
those recommendations everything they're
coming up with really those elements
intertwine with each other so we really
have to have not just working on those
areas but working them together which is
where we're gonna just introduce them
right now
join me and ask a few questions and then
I'll be ready to answer your own
questions and they start with our basic
continuty and that's for Susie Nelson to
start with our vice president and dean
for student life Susie thank you for
joining us today you know I hear from
you and others that the number one
challenge you're facing were all facing
is how to repopulate the campus and
diving
to bring stuff back the fact would be
students and postdocs and so forth your
big responsibility is of course students
and dorms and residence halls so what
what are you views what are you thinking
about repopulating is full when it comes
to residential areas Thank You Raphael
hi everyone thanks so much for joining
today let me just provide a little bit
of context because we actually have two
thousand people living in residence now
we have thirteen hundred graduate
students and two hundred undergraduate
students and around five hundred
partners and spouses and children and
house team members and so as we look to
the fall I will I will say we've been
thinking really hard on this but we
still have a lot more questions than
answers and the main point that I want
to make today is that we really want
students to help us problem-solve and
there's a few ways that they can do that
the first is we have been sending out
some surveys to those who live in
residence and those who live off campus
and we've been asking you to tell us
about your experience and that really
helps us think about what the fall might
look like having a good sense of how it
is for you right now
and the second is yesterday we invited
all students to take a look at a problem
statement that's online and we created a
we solved for fall idea Bank and we
would really like you to engage with us
all the questions that we have there's a
lot of resources there some that Bruce
just mentioned that you could take a
look at but we would like you to engage
with us in that way and we also invite
you to join one of two mini townhall
meetings that we will have after this
big townhall those will be held on
Wednesday May 13th one will be for
graduate students and the other will be
for undergraduates they will be hosted
by our student leaders in our heads of
house so please look for those details
and we really hope that you'll attend
and then finally as we think about these
problems I think they can be framed in
really two goals the first goal
is that we know we will have some new
constraints but how can we look at this
in a creative way and really reimagine
the MIT campus so that it's positive and
special and as intellectually and
personally engaging as we as we want it
to be and then the second big goal is as
we make these decisions how can we be
sure we prioritize community health and
well-being for all who are here on
campus so within these two main goals we
have some considerations that I think
students can think about what values
what all of us can think about what
values should play into these decisions
and how should we make these housing
assignments for our students when they
return what strategies will be the most
effective as we try to manage the spread
of the virus and keep our community
healthy especially in our residence
halls and then finally how do we get
buy-in and how do we communicate
effectively about these new ideas so
that they can be implemented with some
effectiveness we're really fortunate
because we have faculty who live in our
houses and I'm very happy that two heads
of house are joining us today and I want
to they have a lot of experience
certainly as professors but they also
have experience living in residence with
our students so I want to give them a
moment to talk as well about what
they're seeing in the in the residence
halls and how they view this David
singer he's our department head and
professor of political science and he
lives in mcgregor house and
undergraduate community and julie shaw
is a professor in aero-astro and she's
the head of house in our in sydney
pacific which is a graduate student
community so David let's turn to you
first could you offer some thoughts on
what you think about what's before us
this fall I can't thank you Susie happy
to be here when we think about Susie's
questions in the context of the
undergraduate dorms two considerations
jump bail first is that every dorm is
different they range in size from 93 to
500 residents
and they have different configurations
of rooms bathrooms kitchens lounges
dining halls and common spaces and
second each dorm has its own form of
student government that serves as a
steward of that community's traditions
so I think the way forward in the coming
weeks and months will be for each
residential community to think about how
students circulate in each community to
think about how to foster social
interactions in a safe manner and that
we're partnering with modeling experts
from idss and other units then we're
listening to experts like dr. Walker and
for the students in each community to
take the lead in designing new
guidelines that respect the unique
physical and social features of each
community and that also importantly
respect the safety of the more
vulnerable members of each community and
this is MIT so the outcome will be new
traditions it will hopefully be clever
strategies that no one's thought of
before and importantly continuity in
some of the core aspects of residential
life that make MIT a special place to
live and to study great thank you David
Julie what are some of your observations
as head of house in Sidney Pacific thank
you Susie so I'm currently in a dorm
with more than 400 students and I can
say that Sidney Pacific exemplifies
whether thriving campus community looks
like despite these very challenging
circumstances
we have a strong community in sp but
frankly our community did seem to depend
on physical gatherings and back in March
I will admit I did worry for a moment
that social distancing would bring
everything to a halt and that was silly
you know we have weekly movie nights
game nights virtual dinner series group
coloring sessions book club and many
other events continue on both for those
that are on campus and off campus and
it's small efforts to make each other
feel heard and cared for that have gone
a long way our students are not only
coping but they're innovating so
seemingly overnight they mobilize the
collaboration with MIT Medical to
implement suppression measures against
the crown virus
the effort was actually sparked by two
questions in the dorm can we understand
utilization of our common spaces in the
dorms like common kitchens bathrooms
laundry and the risk of exposure to the
virus in these places grad students are
now working to Lincoln lab to help test
and improve privacy preserving mobile
apps that may help in a Learning
residents of potential exposures thanks
to our students there'll be ways from
where to get involved Suman and it's
really all very MIT and it's something
to make us all very proud
Thanks we didn't thanks Julie those are
great thoughts and comments and again we
really appreciate your partnership and
we are looking forward to working
together with the students so please go
to the idea Bank and also join us for
the mini town halls which will be next
week Rafael thank you Susie thank you
very much for everything you do with so
much care for students and today
eventually for joining us as well moving
on to I can any continuity and that
working group is led by in weights our
Vice Chancellor for undergraduate and
graduate education Ian can you tell us a
little bit about the scenarios you're
thinking how are you and begin to
envision options for us for the Fall
Thank You Rafael so I would say first at
a an individual level were anticipating
that we will have staff members faculty
on students who um either may be ill or
may be high risk individuals so that we
could have situations where we have you
know faculty who can't be on the
physical campus and students who can and
vice-versa
so we have to be through two-way remote
capable for much of our curriculum
that's a heavy lift but we're preparing
to do that the bigger question that I
think a lot of people are interested in
is of what will default look like in
terms of how much online education what
we have and how much in person education
what we have and what does it mean to be
socially distanced in
instructional spaces and labs and
project spaces and classrooms and things
like that and you know as I listen to
Bruce it's pretty clear that things are
changing so rapidly that you know one of
the best things that we can do is plan
for multiple different scenarios very
very rigorously and prepare for those
but wait to make decisions until we
learn more so we're planning for things
that go all the way from you know a
fully an online fall to having all the
students back to things that are in
between you know half the students for
half the time and I at least as an
optimist at heart I'm very hopeful that
we will have at least some students on
campus in the fall but it's constrained
obviously by social distancing and by
testing methodologies and things like
that so we're still working with a range
of different scenarios so that we can be
prepared as we learn more in in the
weeks ahead on there's so many people
that are working on this I want to
highlight a sort of a couple individuals
who've been very helpful in thinking
through different aspects of this one is
Rick Dan Heiser the chair of the faculty
who has a you know just a wonderfully
thoughtful way I'm helped you know
reimagine and rebuild policies as we go
through this whole process and so I'll
first turn to Rick and ask if he can
comment a little bit about all of that
because it's just an important part of
moving forward and whatever we do Rick
thanks Ian good afternoon everyone
as I described in an email letter to the
community just this past weekend I'm
leading the academic policy and
regulations team we call a part of
faculty and students which the faculty
officers created in mid-april as a
successor to the emergency academic
regulations or years team you may recall
that it was the year's team that
developed those emergency regulations
including the past no record grading
scheme in effect for the spring so as we
formulate the policies associated with
our act
Demming program for this summer and that
will apply in the fall the apart team
has been guided by several principles
first and foremost our aim is to develop
policies that will promote and support
an educational experience for our
undergraduate and graduate students that
is as full as enriching and as rewarding
as possible at the same time we strive
to recognize and be sensitive to the
fact that individual students and
individual instructors may be facing
very different challenges and obstacles
as we navigate our way through the
current emergency as one example this
week the academic policy team is working
to finalize a plan for student and
subject surveys from the outset the team
recognized that the usual numerical
subject evaluation system was not
appropriate for this unusual semester in
which instructors in many cases had less
than two weeks to jury-rig a remote
version of their subjects sometimes
while simultaneously dealing with health
and personal challenges of their own at
the same time a part appreciates that we
have a responsibility to gather feedback
from and listen to our students and we
do not want to lose the opportunity to
gather valuable input and advice on how
to improve our subjects should it be
necessary to offer remote versions again
in the future
so with the help of advice from students
and the expertise of the MIT teaching
and learning lab I believe that the
system we are developing and will
announce hopefully within a week will
achieve these goals and prove valuable
to the community as we plot our course
forward in the future Ian thanks Rick um
just one of dozens and dozens of
examples where Rick and his team have
worked through faculty committees and
engaging students and things to figure
out how best we can plot the way forward
I'll also note that Rick is one of the
faculty members who had two weeks to
spin his class up on his head and and
jury-rigged it and make it work so
and he also has some personal experience
with that um you know both David and
Julie mentioned that so much is
happening that's just so very MIT Bruce
Walker did as well one of the things
that will happen in the fall no matter
what scenario we have is that they're
going to be a lot of very MIT
experiences and one of the people who's
been helping to imagine those is
associate dean of engineering pick up a
sois I'm gonna ask Apeco to just share a
little bit about that
great thanks Ian yeah I guess I should I
want to start by echoing what what you
just said and what Rick has said which
is that um you know I think the faculty
and students have been put in an
extraordinary position and the sort of
the resilience and the response that
I've seen from both of those communities
have been really remarkable and that
actually fills me with a lot of optimism
for the fall to to the students um you
know I think some of the faculty have
adapted and we're gonna we're gonna get
better it's gonna just get better as we
learn more so you know I think the
what's or the bigger thing that sort of
umbrella thing that I wanted to say is
that I think MIT um has been we've been
sort of at our best when we are stepping
up in the service of the local community
in the service of the nation and in the
service of the world and I think that is
not just true in our research but also
in our educational efforts so one of my
colleagues war in Syria has a fabulous
presentation where he shows the
evolution of the mechanical engineering
curriculum and you see that in the late
1800s when the nation was building
bridges we were teaching metallurgy of
iron you know then we went onto steam
engines and we dropped metallurgy and we
put in thermodynamics and boiler design
you know and then it went up we went on
to electrification and we drop boiler
design and we went on to surveying and
electrical engineering and so you can
see that our programs evolved according
to the national needs and evolved to
address problems that are of immediate
relevance so I think we're going to see
more and more of that I think there are
already a lot of faculty that are doing
that I think you're seeing groups of
that popping up around campus and I
applaud everybody who's putting in that
effort
great thanks Peck oh so I think as I
said independent of what path we choose
in the ball and I'm sort of optimistic
that we'll have a path that has these
some of our students on campus for some
of the time hopefully more that I think
will be some really a great experiences
great learning experiences that befit mi
t--'s history and mission going forward
and obviously happy to take lots of
questions on that later thanks Raphael
taken things to sa again as I said
publicly I think you an admirer for all
the work you've done it's almost heroic
to bring it to this point and pick one
we thank you also for joining us in this
in this joining well you have no choice
you have students you have to teach but
thank you anyway let's move on to space
and we have associate provost christie
of a bit we mix the working group of
space use and christian the question
that some people have is well we have
government guidelines on say distancing
how how do you anticipate us practicing
those guidelines in our classrooms
Christine are you there somewhere I am
thanks Raphael that's a very reasonable
question to ask of course it's on all of
our minds as we bring even more people
onto the campus as Suzy mentioned we
have people who are on the campus now
but as we bring more people back how
will we do this and I think this is a
puzzle we enjoy solving puzzles at MIT
and we have a very active and dedicated
group who are thinking about this but
what's already clear is that there will
be a lower density of people in any
given space so if you think about a
lecture hall there will be fewer people
in that lecture hall but the education
should and will be just as vibrant but
it's not just the lecture halls which
are obvious it's how will we do
performance base
and project-based learning and
laboratory based learning so we're
thinking about that from every
curriculums perspective what will the
classroom of the future when we bring
more students back to campus look like
and I think it's important to be aware
that that will always have a few things
in mind it's not just about bringing the
students back to campus but it's about
the well-being of the students and the
faculty and the staff and that's all
equally important and and here the staff
are the people who help to design and
deliver those classes to clean the
restrooms and the buildings and the
laboratories to take care of the
research teams and the administration
and so as we think all about all of
those people being in the buildings
together we think about the well-being
and the flexibility and the adaptability
as as being important parts of the
planning Kristen thank you you've done
an amazing job I think you're the only
one or one of the very few that is
allowed to go into every single space on
campus but don't let anybody else but
that's not very beauteous privilege that
you give yourself Kristen thank you for
the work you do you're very you're very
welcome and I should say we're all eager
to get back to the campus Raphael the
picture behind me I did take a couple of
weeks ago so you're right I have the
privilege of getting to the Cielo campus
in its current state but I'm just as
eager to be back in my lab in my
classroom as anyone else I agree with
you Kristen thank you so let's move on
to the research engine lots of people
are asking when are we going to bring
that research engine back and Maria
Zuber sees our VP for research and
hopefully she is ready to answer that
question Maria please hi everybody so
our efforts in the research Enterprise
are in two critical areas the first is
funding continuity and the second is
planning for a phased opening of our
research labs in a way that prioritizes
the safety of both the MIT and the
surrounding communities so in the area
of funding we're closely monitoring our
current grants and future funding
opportunities federal agencies under OMB
guidance have given great
flexibility in the execution of current
grants for a period of 90 days and we're
working with government colleagues and
our peer institutions to advocate for
not only funding enhancements to
existing grants but also talking about
the importance of proceeding with new
proposal solicitations or non-federal
partners and foundations and especially
in industry are undergoing extraordinary
financial challenges and we're in
communication with many of them to try
to minimize the impacts to our
researchers and we're working with our
vice president for finance here and the
provost understand the extent of our
exposure so we can develop mitigating
strategies now to plan for the ramp up
of labs I instituted a faculty-led
process I held virtual meetings with
over 20 Department Lab and center heads
to receive input on the factors that
they considered important in restarting
research on campus I then formed a
committee representing a subset of this
group supplemented by critical staff and
shared by Professor Tyler Jack's to
develop guidelines for ramp up which we
distributed widely for comment the
issues raised were not all academic for
example among the most often cited needs
are on-campus parking and childcare the
committee is now coalescing the input to
develop an implementation plan for a
phased lab opening while we don't have a
firm date yet to announce at this time
we're following the guidelines from the
Massachusetts state officials very
closely and I'm now going to turn it
over to Tyler to provide an update on
the committee's activities well thanks
very much Maria and good afternoon
everybody let me say at the outset that
this was a very engaged process that
involved nine MIT faculty members and
several senior MIT staff who worked
really effectively to come up with a set
of guidelines to think about a sensible
way to come back to our research
activities I'll talk about those in some
detail in a second but let me start by
making a few general points the first is
that although most of our research
activities have moved to the off-campus
setting
over the last couple of months there is
significant research taking place at MIT
including quite a lot in the area of
koban 19 research and Bruce Walker
actually mentioned some of that earlier
and that's quite exciting secondly when
Maria constituted the committee she was
very clear about the scope and
specifically that it related to research
that needed access to laboratories or
needed access to equipment in order to
be done and therefore we assumed that
the current policy that work that can be
done remotely will be done remotely will
stay in place during this phase of the
research ramped up and the third general
point is that we recognize that when we
come back to campus in this fashion
there will be individuals who cannot or
choose not to come back for a variety of
reasons and so the committee was very
clear that with respect to all members
of research teams coming back it would
be voluntary with respect to the
planning itself the committee took the
approach that we wanted to get back to
research we're all anxious to get back
to research but we have to do it in a
fashion that represents the safest
possible set of practices so therefore
we anticipate starting with a
low-density work environment as Kristen
described that will allow us to be well
within CDC guidelines in terms of safe
work practices and overtime as
conditions allow we envision future
phases that allow more individuals on
campus at a given time to stay within
the prescribed density and occupancy
occupancy parameters groups will have to
develop shift work schedules either
multiple shifts per day or alternative
day schedules the committee left the
development of these plans to each
individual faculty member or principal
investigator with overhead oversight
from their dlc heads we've also
discussed additional safety measures
that have been already described on this
in this meeting and these will include
mandated use of personal protective
equipment daily health checks as well as
frequent
sanitization of personal workspaces and
common areas
lastly the committee was clear about the
need during the ramped up phase to
integrate the level of research activity
across campus so is to ensure that
shared research facilities as well as
MIT Central Services are not
overburdened and that the staff
performing these functions also have
safe work so I'll stop there and turn it
back to you Maria okay and obviously in
all of this planning we've been assisted
by our medical professionals and also
we've gotten a lot of help from
Kristen's office and space and many
others so Rafi I'll turn it back to you
Thank You Maria and think you'd better
look I mean needless to say the research
Enterprise is so important to all of us
I'm grateful that that people as visa
the two of you are willing to just give
us so much of your time to make sure
that we'll bring that back much
appreciated
let's move quickly to community and and
and related issues I think we're ready
to go to the Q&A but I would like us to
install on our culture and community
and for that we have Ramona Allen our VP
for human resources and we have Jill
Dozier our community and equity officer
let's start with Ramona Ramona whatever
we do we have about 10,000 people like
to work you so whatever we do thinking
about faculty and students clearly we
have to think about this stuff too there
are significant fraction of MIT episode
what do you know about how is it stuff
doing how do they enjoy working from
home harder for the young I think I
think staff are coping pretty well
actually I think they've done
extraordinary things over the past
several weeks I guess it's eight weeks
now it's hard to believe that that much
time that's gone by I think they're
doing extremely well but there are also
some concerns you know staff want to
come back to campus just like everybody
else they're interested in helping get
our community back up and running and
they want to support all the efforts of
the faculty and the students as well
when they
we miss each other we want to be around
each other we're social beings we need
to be together I think you know when you
look at all these scenarios we have to
think about how this is going to apply
to staff and I think first and foremost
you know when people return to campus
and OH probably be in a phased way staff
need to understand those of us
especially in administrative roles that
we might not be the first people to be
asked to come back to campus I mean I'm
in that category when I look at
administrative people across the campus
right that's many of us who might not be
in the first round of the reentry
process and so I think people have to be
patient with that and be understanding
because when you bring staff back to the
campus you know that means more
deliveries more other staff will be
needed to be on campus will than I need
more facility staff more more police
more security you name it right so it
that just increases things overall for
every single category we also have to
look at how people get to campus right
so if people are taking public
transportation for example you're going
to have more people on these trains now
it's my understanding that there's some
social distancing measures that are
being implemented on subway systems so
that people will feel safe when they're
coming to work because sometimes that's
the only way many of us can get to work
so those are a few things so there are
people who you will need to have back on
campus pretty quickly and then there are
those who may have to wait people we are
allowed back on campus and it's
basically for our own safety and we have
to just be patient about that there's
their masks what happens with you know
if Cambridge is requiring everybody to
wear masks do we provide those masks do
we ask visitors to wear them how do we
enforce all it lots of things that are
in play here and lots of people around
campus who are thinking about this
deeply who care about it and we've been
spending a lot of time light so I think
in general staff
by handling things very well I think
they are eager to get back to campus
just like everybody else so thank you
thank you and thank you for what you do
with the char I really appreciate it
John you have been at MIT for how long
already full of 45 days well I'll give
you are you aren't you're you always
have a degree of relief I hear that
you're organizing a service for all
staff students and faculty so think it
tell us a little more about sure thing
Thank You Raphael one of the
characteristics that makes MIT special
regard many ways both formal and
informal that we can connect and engage
with others in our community the sense
of connection belonging inclusion is
vital not only to the strength of the
community but also to the health and
well-being people in it we therefore
must ensure that weird we continue
benefiting to the greatest extent
possible from the diversity of people
perspectives experiences and engagement
opportunities that enrich our individual
and collective teaching learning
research scholarship work and decision
making while doing so and what is for
most of us are completely online
environment I'm working with Tim Jamison
and Marian Kurt Brock
to lead a community continuity group
that's comprised of a representative
team will guide both short-term efforts
and a longer-term strategy that's
focused on these concerns we initially
responded to a rising community need for
central information and assembled most
of our online community support
resources in one place on the iceo
website with a link to this information
on the table of 19 website but Raphael
regarding how we will gain an
understanding how our community is doing
specifically we understand that there
are many needs that exist amongst
members of our community since the
beginning of our response to the current
crisis but today we have little
empirical evidence of the scope and
scale of these needs as such we're
tapping into our faculty expertise and
working with institutional research to
administer a series of pulse surveys
short surveys that take a few minutes to
complete that will help us to better
understand where to target our attention
and resources
thereby maximizing sense of community
connectedness and belonging to all
students postdocs staff and faculty this
is one of the many tools that we'll be
using stay connected understand and
respond to our community's evolving
needs in an ongoing fashion during the
uncertain times ahead of us our plan is
to launch the first survey before the
end of this month and we will of course
share the results with the MIT community
if anyone has questions or
recommendations for the community
continuity group I ask that you email us
a community continuity at mit.edu thanks
raffia
John thank you so much thank you for
joining us and I bet you those 49 days
have not been boring at all they haven't
thank you John so let's now move to the
Q&A part of the conversation let me just
say that for this part of the
conversation we have also joining us to
answer questions our provost Manish
Mayta Chancellor mone cindy bonner our
vp for open learning sanjay sharma and
our VP and general counsel might give a
sense so Alfred do you have any
questions rising up at the top that you
want to answer yes indeed we have a
whole bunch of questions nearly 200 at
this point and they've all been terrific
so just a quick reminder from me that as
we move into the Q&A remind you you can
still submit questions using the link
near the bottom of your screen we're not
going to try and answer in the order in
which these came in instead we're
focusing on the most frequent questions
and just a reminder of course there are
some questions we simply don't have
answers for just yet but we'll let you
know what we know at this stage and so
Raphael by my reckoning here the
certainly the number one questions have
to do with budget and financial support
for students well I think the most
frequently asked question so far has to
do with tuition in the fall if it's
going to be a fall semester primarily
online will that affect tuition that's
one question and a related one is has to
do with our support for graduate
students we know that there has been a
petition circulating to ensure that grad
students get the support
they need and that's a question that's
been coming up as well let's see what
the body our management of promise why
do you think can you answer those
questions one institution in the fall as
I think the way understood enough for
the if it goes online what one without
the nutrition and support progress to
this and the petition Mari are you on
yeah can you hear me become accustomed
to turn off the mute so yeah let me try
and answer that Raphael as you know
under our normal process each year we
announce tuition and financial aid in
the early spring and that's exactly what
we did this year where we announced
tuition and fees for next year would
increase by three point eight percent
but we also announced an increase in the
undergraduate financial aid budget a
seven point eight percent and just as a
footnote our undergraduate financial aid
budget for the coming fiscal year we
budgeted at a hundred and forty eight
million dollars but clearly these are no
longer normal times and we're focused on
trying to determine what the fall and
spring will look like without that
picture it's really hard to think about
tuition in the normal way in which we do
it so our focus right now is what will
the fall in spring look like and then
we'll just we'll make determinations
about the financial needs for the
students and and the tuition I will say
that well in our remodeling process as
we experienced in the 2009 crisis we
fully anticipate that's a students need
for support will go up as you don't have
to look any further than the thirty
million people that have a pilot for
unemployment and so for that purpose we
have actually increased even beyond 147
million our budgeted financial aid
budget for next year the last thing I
think it's important for me to point out
is when we're thinking about tuition
tuition it's important to recognize that
sixty percent of our undergraduates
today receive MIT scholarships and
actually 31 percent of the
undergraduates don't pay tuition based
upon the important need so
the question on tuition I think you also
asked about what we're doing for the
graduate students and this is an area
we've been working really hard on with
both the deans the Vice Chancellor and
the Chancellor Cindy Barnhart I'll say a
few things and then Cindy may want to
say more after maybe just to correct
things and I don't get right we're
taking this issue in several steps the
first step is really to address the
concerns about summer support so last
week we announced the establishment of a
short-term emergency fund that's going
to address instances where students
summer plans have been disrupted and
they need support there's a lot of
diversity in the amount and type of need
that's needed and this is really based
on the vast variety of graduate programs
that we have and for that reason we're
workship working with each school and
college team to ensure that we have the
resources to address the full need for
their particular programs and that those
resources are allocated in a way that's
appropriate for the multiple need I'm
confident that we can meet the full need
of those schools but we have to address
it at that local level in terms of
assessing the need and Retin as recently
as today with the deans to confirm our
plans and review them the second step is
really to address impacts that koba 19
is having on students progress towards
their degree and the legitimate concerns
about whether or not they're going to be
supported into the fall term what that
means about their support degrees
extensions and the like and that's where
it will turn our attention next once we
have the summer support issue nailed
which is obviously the most pressing I'd
also say that I'm really pleased to say
that last week we announced that we
accepted the recommendation developed by
the graduate student councils graduate
stipend committee where will be
increasing graduate student stipends by
2.9 percent and that we've also
announced that health insurance rates
for our medical medical plans will not
increase in the coming year so those are
the things I wanted to share I don't
know Cindy you want to add more or back
to you Raphael
good job thank you money I'm afraid
another one yeah I sure do in that same
vein I a number of people are asking
about our support for international
students who
face other kinds of hurdles some of them
financial but of course questions of
travel bans and visa issues so a number
of questions are asking how MIT plans to
support our international students very
good question I'm Maria Zuber before
research okay so I'll start and then
Cindy may may want to jump in so we're
monitoring the situation closely of
course you know we continue to be in
contact with our colleagues in
Washington to to try to you know explain
the importance of getting these
international scholars onto our campuses
we're monitoring the situation situation
closely and and we're in touch with
these students to try to essentially be
ready to hit Send as soon as as soon as
this the visa situation opens up to get
everything submitted on time
Cindy do you want to add anything to
that work sure so we understand that
there are a number of circumstances
beyond the usual circumstances of
international students and scholars
being able to freely come to MIT and to
stay at MIT and so we're looking at a
number of different scenarios in which
we understand that potentially there
might be remote research morell remote
learning and we are we have a small
group right now looking at all those
situations to see how we can have what
the options are what our flexibility is
what the legal constraints may be what
negative effects some of our practices
might have on people's visa statuses if
they're now in their home country and
may not return all with the
understanding that we want to support
the continuing scholarship and education
of our international students
as well as the new community members
that are coming to MIT so all I can say
is we're working hard we're trying to
have flexible options we're working with
the international students office the
international scholars office as well as
a vice president finance office in my
office to come up with a scenario to
understand both the compliance issues as
well as to ensure that we're providing
as much flexible options for our
international students and scholars
Thank You Marco I just that for good to
us Marie a question can I Maria can you
say something I want you to see you on
the screen okay the first time hold I
asked you what was your screen
background and I have to ask that
question to you again what's the screen
background okay well the last time I was
on Mars and I'm still on Mars but I'm in
a different place I'm actually in the
western part of the Valles Marineris
which is a canyon that's about as wide
as the United States
I'm afraid another one sure do and this
again is coming from a number of folks
so let me start here and actually maybe
Bruce will help us with these questions
it goes back to how will we ensure
safety on campus Raphael when and if
students are returning in the fall a few
questions related to that a lot are
asking how will we ensure the safety of
students and staff on campus a related
question is will MIT supply facemasks
and the third in this group is do face
masks do the trick and do we need social
distancing if we're all wearing masks
well clearly I think that Bruce is a
little more qualified than I am to
answer the question of is a face mask
all we need I think but what I can say
is that we will consider seriously about
how the supply of face masks and how to
make things easy for everybody in the
community that is over going but in
terms of are we gonna be asking
everybody to wear masks if a decision is
made today we
we know today miss Brewster so that I'm
wrong as with yes will we know anything
in four weeks or eight weeks during four
months to decide differently
perhaps I'll leave that crystal ball up
to Bruce but I think as you heard
Bruce's comments earlier facemask Issa
is a safe way to proceed with the
knowledge we have ourselves today and
we're running along those lines but
Bruce do you all want anything to what I
said yeah just to agree that I think
face masks are really a kid a critical
component here and I think there's every
reason to believe that coming back to
campus is going to be associated with
everybody wearing face masks it's hard
for me to believe that by September that
will not still be a recommendation thank
you Bruce may I go ahead someone else
was speaking I think that there was a
sort of related question about if one
wears a face mask does one not need to
do social distancing and I think the the
simple answer is everything helps so
most likely face max will be part of the
process and one will be advised to
practice social distancing policies for
the foreseeable future facie title means
that's won't appreciate it thank you
I'm phreak you have another one yes and
this is another very very popular
question having to do with when we think
we'll be able to make decisions about
the fall rifle well let me just say that
that this is a pretty serious question
that we are thinking about in a daily
basis pretty much with what I know today
and again every ly heavily with advice
from people like Bruce and Tyler earlier
people who understand this much more
than I do
I would like to wait for as long as
possible that we know things might still
change I doubt that even if things are
still changing
we wait much longer than eight weeks to
make the decision so I would say that
late June early July there abouts we
should know enough to try to make the
right decision for the campus but as you
heard from Bruce earlier things are
changing very rapidly and we're
monitoring that very rapidly if at some
point in time between now and then we
understand that things won't change much
we'll be ready to make a decision about
what things are changing and we're
learning more and more every day
I think they write responsible thing to
do is to wait until the last possible
moment over not much later than I every
July or so to make that decision that's
what we are at this point Raphael I
might add that I think that the the fact
that matter is that they at the Brigham
and Women's Hospital I learned this this
morning there are despite all the kovat
patients there despite all the activity
in the chaos that's accompanied this
surge and in Boston there have been only
two cases of transmission to health care
workers that were documented to have
that could be attributed to something
happening within the hospital
obviously MIT is not the same as being
inside the Brigham but it really it
really points the fact that judicious
use of face masks is something that
really does make a difference social
distancing is not as possible in the
hospital so it's probably not adhere to
as much but to tyler's point social
distancing will also have to be
something that's that that's implemented
and maintained Thank You Rosa
thanks Alfred you have any other
questions I sure do and this one Rafael
is maybe more specifically for you and
maybe Ramona president ryf he wrote last
month that you'll do everything you can
to avoid cutting jobs is that still the
case well let me see however more
answers the nay-no trying to correct
what she says Ramona you the shot
absolutely
so layoffs are a last resort always none
of us wants to go through that activity
we under
in the economic climate we know that if
you were to leave MIT to the loss of job
you're going out into a really tough
situation we are trying to avoid that at
all costs so we're doing everything we
can to think this through and make sure
a number of people weigh in in those
decisions are taking very seriously so
the goal is to avoid layoffs at all
costs
Thank You Ramona I fully agree with her
excellent I'm sure community continues
to find that reassuring I want to turn
to a series of questions now about
students who are considering perhaps
taking a gap year or new students who
may be considering deferring a lot of
questions have come in about what would
we say to a student who is considering
either one of those
what's our what would we say and and I
hear I think I know that's Ian and his
group may want to answer here and yeah I
can I can see that any a lot of people
would want to jump and answer that
question so Ian Beco Cindy who was a big
day who wants to be the first they're
fighting already
go ahead I shared these the positive
news that we I think we had a record
undergraduate yield this year and our
graduate yield was very high too so a
lot of people are still very excited
about coming to MIT I think the hard
question for everyone in thinking about
deferrals is what will the the
alternatives be at that point in time
and and that's just a very hard thing to
consider but as with most things at MIT
where we would you know do what's in the
best interest of the students I think if
the students felt that it was best for
them to defer we would you know let them
defer so you know those are the kinds of
things that you know we will I think
learn more about as we understand more
about what the fall will look like it on
the undergraduate side especially but
it's a hard question because we have
ideas of what the campus environment
will look like but we don't know what
the alternatives for people pursuing on
internships or travel which is likely to
be difficult still will be and as I said
earlier we hope to create still a
vibrant environment on campus where
students get to spend time with other
students and learn about great things so
hard question to answer thank you and
does anybody else want I'll just I'll
just second what Ian said which is that
I I'm not sure that the question is much
different now than it is at any time
right at any time your way what which is
the option that's better for the student
and I think we would do the same thing
now I think I think the main point is
that we really are going to try to as we
do every year try to make it very
attractive and exciting for a student to
be engaged whether that's on campus so
maybe some time away from campus we will
do we will offer students an experience
that they would never forget that is
very much MIT that is for a certain
outfit you got anymore
yes I have one or two more Raphael and
again I'm picking questions or my group
is picking questions that are most
frequently asked here's another one that
I think is related which is it says
transitioning to college is hard doing
it online would be even harder how would
you support first-year students if we're
still doing remote teaching even if
we're on campus while we're doing it and
I think this is a great opportunity for
us to share a little bit of whether
students are coming us from their own
experience if you want or your son Jake
and do that yeah actually or or maybe
since I expect he it has a lot of
insight into how our students are
reaching out both at CPW but also
planning for fall events David singer I
expect
um could give us a real
boots-on-the-ground kind of a view about
how our students hope to welcome other
students
ya know I'm happy to speak about that
you know I think that our students are
already creatively reaching out and
trying to maintain a sense of community
even without the you know the benefit of
physical presence and so the the student
governance process still continues the
meeting still continued there was a lot
of efforts to reach out to students
during CPW that went really well and was
just as creative and as quirky and as
quintessentially MIT as it always is and
so I expect that's going to continue and
so if you know we're in a difficult
situation in the fall where they're
still distance and they're still
students who are not on campus then the
the students the upper class students
will reach out to them and form a sense
of community so that when we finally do
reunite on campus it's going to feel
like you know that there actually was
continuity and thank you David thanks
Alfred
I just want to see if anyone wants to
add to that about the support for
first-year students if there's anything
else on anyone's mind just before we go
on because I'm going to shift gears now
to housing if there's nothing more to be
said on that okay great so the question
is several things and Suzy Nelson maybe
this comes back to you having to do with
when will we announce decisions about
housing assignments number one number
two are we looking at the fraternities
and sororities and other independent
living arrangements and how do they
factor into the mix and the third
question is what's the thinking around
fall sports this is all Suzy thank you
Alfred for that question so the first
one about assignments we we we don't
really want to start making assignments
until we know what the program will be
the academic program will be so we're we
have a lot of different models we had a
good conversation with dorm Khan last
week and one of the things we talked
about
the students suggested that perhaps we
would do this goes back to supporting
first year students then maybe we would
do a virtual assignment for new students
based on their preference so that would
be a very nice thing because then
upperclassmen could connect right away
with new students depending upon where
they get assigned to their house so so
more to come on assignments and when
that will all roll out and it will
probably align with when a decision is
made about when we start and how we
start and how many people will be back
and that relates to the second part of
your question which was fraternities
sororities and independent living groups
they are a very important part of our
experience on campus and we absolutely
are thinking about the FSI oh geez and
how they will be linked in with the
housing process we house about 1,100
students in our FSI oh geez ordinarily
so they're very important for housing
but they're also very important for the
just the social life on campus the the
student social life and organizational
involvement that students have and then
about athletics no real decision has
been made with athletics the NCAA has
yet they're they're looking to advise
schools and our conference is also that
we've formed a working group to think
about this and what it means for MIT and
members of our conference but decisions
have not been made yet thank you Susie
Alfred I guess the next one Raffaele is
how are we going to support staff who
feel uncomfortable returning to
on-campus work but who may feel peer
pressure or direct pressure to return to
campus what's our overall approach to
supporting staff in a gradual transition
back to campus both those who are eager
to come and those who may be a little
bit more concerned Ramona you're looking
a crack at it sure so for people who are
concerned our recommendation is always
talk to your manager your supervisor and
we can hear what those concerns are
and then make some adjustments
accordingly the goal is not to have
anybody come back and feel uncomfortable
about it you know I think they'll it
could be some level of uncertainty when
we come back it's all it's going to feel
new for us coming back to campus after
being away for so long and then coming
back and it fades away but I think if
you talk this through with your local
administration and if they need to
consult with Human Resources they should
do that and I'm sure we'll come up with
a supportive plan that will make people
feel as comfortable as possible under
the circumstances
welcome here's one more Raphael
maybe sanjay has something to contribute
here or maybe you do too and this is a
question about what we're learning from
other countries who may be further along
on the timeline of reopening college and
university campuses and are we in touch
with them and what are we hearing and
how are we integrating that into our
thinking yeah maybe I like to bounce the
question to Ian because we did MIT did
reach out to a number of universities
around the world and get some feedback
but Ian's been collecting that because
he's trying to put that into our
thinking for the Fall
Ian's not sure actually ie that the
person who is collecting is is Richard
Lester who did a marvelous job
crowdsourcing it through a lot of
faculty members so we have lots of
information from again a
boots-on-the-ground kind of a look at
different universities and then through
Rafael's efforts I we've begun to
establish some discussions with some
universities at a higher level from
around the world to see what we can
learn a little bit in advance to sort of
see how things are going as they begin
to repopulate their campus so the short
answer is yes we are reaching out to
individuals and at Rafael's level of
course universities leadership to
understand how things are going what
their practices and policies are and
what we're learning I would say is exam
be what Bruce and Tyler and others said
which is masks masked mask social
distancing phased very careful very
thoughtful and most of them most of you
to university that have given us
information and very early stages
baby steps yeah I think that the masks
is absolutely key here one of the things
that I was suiting with somebody in
Guangzhou this morning the University
there which is very close to one and had
a had the Serge go through that city
they've opened up and they're using
temperature monitoring also as a way to
try and identify those that that are you
know that is a as a sentinel feature of
a of a new infection so but but you know
the reality is they've they've they're
not seeing or surgeons so far in those
communities with those implementations
so that also I think makes us all feel
more confident that that's a good way
forward yes and the only thing that I
can add at a high level but we are
really collecting all that information
as you've heard from others the only
other point I can add that hasn't be
said is is that in many labs they are
the social distancing is also being
translated to a timeshare so there are
ships to work in the lab whether it's a
days and evenings or eight hours so
whether it's a Monday Wednesday Friday
use the furthest Saturday I mean there
are there are all sort of different
variations on how to handle their
activity in intense it many laughs they
base it is pretty high in terms of
interaction and and and and what I've
seen done and I have not seen that
separate face mask always present but
also much more separation among people
in laboratories but anyway we're
collecting all that information nothing
that we have heard and I know just for
what I have read I haven't not seen the
whole thing very organized a feedback
that I've gotten
directly that I've read is everything
consistent what we're here from goose
and Tyler and all other experts so it's
all trying to do the same thing what we
are trying to get in addition to what
they are doing
is the results are getting so Bruce you
just heard was describing how a bigger
my women's they have a particular
database and you can you can we can
learn from so I think that part is also
I'm trying to understand so I can
compare we can compare how effective
some institutions are applying the same
kinds of safety procedures or protocols
and others I'm Fred Orman how are we
doing we're doing well I just want to
let folks know that we're coming to
toward the end of the time we advertise
but I think we're going to run a few
extra minutes here just so we can cover
a couple extra questions and then I know
we have a story we want to share with
the community as we wrap but let me just
get a few quick lightning round
questions and if I could and hopefully
we can get through these quickly here's
a question for Ramona about child care
as MIT thinking about supporting child
care options as we begin reopening in
the late summer and fall
so we're examining all options right now
we're looking for ways to make
enhancements to the child care benefits
that we currently have and we can't do
anything with daycare centers until the
governor lifts the restriction but we
have a lot of people thinking about that
issue as well we know the importance of
this especially for faculty who have to
come back and teach online if children
aren't at camps or in daycare centers so
we're we're examining all of those
possibilities and trying to be creative
on top of it super Thank You Ramona
Sanjay one for you because I know you've
been thinking about how to bring the
voices of alumni into your planning for
2021 and beyond and that is a question
from alumni will they have a chance to
offer insights and advice as you do your
work if I wrapped absolutely I think
they're all trying to figure out a new
normal here and there's they've been
references to crystal ball and the
community is the crystal ball and our
alums will be a will will be advisors to
the
for some Rick and I welcome their advice
in fact we will set up an advisory board
for the task force and performance
fantastic Kristin and lightning-round
question for you will there be a
facility for self isolation on campus if
we have faculty staff students who get
sick that's a great question so we have
that facility now for the folks who are
on campus and we do think that there
will be for a time waves of infection or
at least the potential for waves of
infection in the area so we are working
on plans to have isolation facilities as
part of caring for the resident
community just as a reminder we have
that for the resident community now as
well as the Collier Care Center for
folks who aren't part of the resident
community but are part of the MIT
community and need that isolation so
it's a resource now it's a resource that
we will continue in our planning Thank
You Kristen
Raphael I'm going to come to you in just
one second but there's one question I
wanted to make sure we addressed for
Susie and that is there's a few students
who tell us that they're struggling with
with mental health in this difficult
time and what advice can we offer and
how can they gain support thank you for
that question so I think what's most
important is don't suffer alone please
reach out to us because we are
absolutely here for you all of our
resources are available online and
there's a great website which we will
post after this session so that you can
have easy access to it the other thing I
would say is make sure you're doing all
those things those common sense kind of
things to take care of yourself and you
know eating right getting enough sleep
taking a break from zoom getting
outdoors if you can and doing something
positive for yourself and and I guess
the last thing I would say is what I
have been doing is thinking a lot about
what is right before me that I can
control and do today and not worrying so
much about those things that I are
unknowns and I can't really do much
about today so it's kind of like the
song at the very
the session pick yourself up and start
all over again
I think it's been very tough for many of
us to do that because it's it's it's
been a very challenging time so please
reach out there are many who can can
support you right now thank you so much
Suzie just to know we've had over 500
questions and one of the final ones
Rafael is for you and very much on the
same theme
how do you stay positive during this
crisis oh yeah I appreciate a question
I'm surprised by it but thank you I look
I think there is a lot of suffering out
there let me just start with that
because I feel it very strongly I'm all
like I'm sure many of you know people
who have lost jobs know that they might
be but elsewhere I know people who have
lost loved ones so there is a lot of
suffering out there and that can bring
you down but it might be a fantastic
place I'm just simply thrilled and
fortunate that I work in a place in
which it's uplifting everybody sees a
problem they want to fix they want to do
something about it when this thing
started they swirl the community just
cut up and try to figure out how to be
helped and I'm gonna come back with a
moment so it's a place when I came to
argue - it's a place where it's
optimistic it's a place that believes
that intellectual brainpower education
science technology I can make a
difference and that just keeps you going
every day and that's that's just part of
the DNA of MIT I'm just very lucky to be
Thank You Raphael and so I think that
brings us to the end of the Q&A and I
just want to remind everyone that there
we had such a number of terrific
questions we will be trying to answer
many of these questions online on the
cove at 19 pages of the MIT website so
we'll let you know when we've answered
many more of your excellent questions
but I think we got to everything that
was asked multiple times
Raphael so thank you and the entire
panel for that and now Raphael back to
you thank you offered so I this is
actually it
other way you answer the question to us
Alfred I want to just spend just a
couple of minutes and with a help of a
faculty member showing how it might be
has responded to such a difficult
difficult situation as you heard earlier
we have more than 60 faculty that are
involved in all sort of efforts in
response to Cobie 19 whether is
providing life-saving medical supply
advanced testing bruce mention about
developing new therapies and treatments
and even at NC exceeds and somebody may
be working in cooperation with Bruce and
the revenues if it's so it's an amazing
place how very quickly people figure out
I know how to do this I can help even if
that thought what they were doing for
research but I want to just highlight
one of them is an amazing colleague of
ours his name is Simon Jones so he's a
professor at MIT Sloan School of
Management and he has been part of an
effort to help nursing homes nursing
homes across the state to face the
crisis so Simon what can you tell us
about what you've been doing Thank You
Rafael well as you just mentioned we
went all-in on cover 19 like many of our
colleagues and many people who are
listening to this broadcast our focus we
decided about eight weeks ago was to try
and help nursing homes assisted living
in other senior care withstand this
incredible and dangerous surge of of
covered 19 and we work long and hard to
try and figure out how to do this and
and about five weeks ago I had a meeting
with the head of the Massachusetts
Senior Care Association Tara Gregorio
and I thought at that point that we'd
learned a lot and we were quite expert
in in my view about what what we could
provide them what nursing homes needed
and Tara said to me you know Simon
there's one thing we need I'm really
only one thing right now and that's more
testing and at that moment I said myself
that's the one thing we can't do I don't
know how to get more testing and
unfortunately my colleague Brett said
lemme who's the brains behind this and
had the original one of the original
ideas said to me Simon
call up the Broad Institute and see if
we can get some of their tests and and
they did provide those tests and we
connected them with mer senior care and
and then we need a test tube's so so
where did we get testers where do we
need to get the test kits to make this
happen
MIT Medical came provers and and again
and again this has been what our
experience Rafael which is we work the
problem we try to be smart about it we
are MIT and we find colleagues we have
more than 10 faculty at MIT who worked
on this we find students more than 50
students have helped us with some aspect
to this we find people all around campus
who are willing to give us ideas or test
tubes or swabs or autoclave the swabs
whatever it is whatever it takes
there's always somebody in the MIT
Network and then there are the friends
of MIT there are people in the alumni
network
there's the Schmidt Futures Foundation
which gave us a key early grant to make
this work happen
there's the Biogen foundation which came
through with a big additional grant just
now that has in turn unlocked I would
say a change in in mindset and
understanding of the state level and the
state is now provided a hundred and
thirty million dollars to help nursing
homes and assisted living in other
facilities around the state and now the
real work begins because they've
provided the states provided the money
but what's the strategy how are you
gonna do it how you gonna take ideas
such as the one put forward by Bruce
Walker several times today
masks how do you provide better PPE for
the people working these nursing homes
how do you improve infection control how
do you make sure there are enough
workers who are willing and able to work
now I don't have all the answers but the
community does the people people around
Massachusetts do we can connect with
them we can provide end-to-end solutions
we can provide all the logistics
necessary to get the right experts from
MIT and through other other places and
other hospitals and even I would say
other universities use that word
carefully in the community apply to this
problem to help all the residents and
all the staff in every single nursing
home and assisted living in
Massachusetts and then Rafael the
question is and this question was put me
by the Biogen foundation people this
afternoon they said this is great Simon
making progress but when can we take
this model and these ideas and show it
to the rest of the country and help
people everywhere
in the United States think about how to
protect the older members of their
communities and everyone who works with
them and tries to keep them safe so it
doesn't end Rafael it keeps it keeps
going it keeps working and thank your FL
and thank you everyone here for your
leadership and your inspiration in this
school times thank you for your
inspiration let me tell the thousands of
people watching in the town hall that be
beware of Simon Johnson he is a very
dangerous man this guy a few weeks ago
maybe a month ago so not two months ago
so I think he called on a Sunday
afternoon or two o'clock and he tells me
you gotta give me the governor tonight
at 7 p.m. at 7:00 you are crazy
what for and he explained it to me and
if it someone if every one of a thousand
faculty members say I want to see the
governor you think I should called and
no but this is you have to do that well
I be and he showed up and he heard the
idea and then good things happen so be
careful with this guy he doesn't stop I
want to tell you all that I got a letter
based on the work that Simon bean
another a few days ago for the head of
the State Association for senior care
and in that letter he referred to Simon
and his MIT team who supported them
through this very dark days as our
guardian angels so it gives me
goosebumps Simon thank you so much for
all you're doing for the people who many
people have just just forgotten thank
you so much well we're done for the day
and definitely stand Hall I want to
thank all the panelists for
participating and for the openness I
want to thank all of you for
participating from all over the world as
you heard from us we are facing
difficult decisions they are very
complex and we're going to find ways to
invite all of you who want to contribute
to offer your ideas I also want to
repeat again as I started at the
beginning that we want to make this is
based in with respect for everyone's
opinions and experiences and with
empathy and compassion and I may
conclude with something that I've said
the end of the last town hall we may be
in 10,000 places where a steel one MIT
and as they say in my hometown where I
come from
hasta la vista thank you thank you all
for joining us and thank you Raphael
just to remind you a recording will be
available at this URL shortly for those
of you who can't wait to watch again
and please music maestro close us out we
can work it out
by the Beatles John and Paul
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You Martin